a resource consent is permission to
undertake an activity or to construct a
building that does not comply with the
district plan rules it requires you to
consider the effects of your projects on
the environment the community and your
neighbors
you'll also need a results content for
subdividing the land or resource consent
is different from a building consent
which covers how something is
constructed to comply with the Building
Act to apply for resource consent you
will need to compile the relevant
documentation for a subdivision you will
need a surveyor to produce survey plans
otherwise the plans would usually be
drawn by an architect or draftsperson
one of the most important things you'll
need to provide is an assessment of the
environmental effects an AE e you can
ask a consultant planner surveyor or
architect to prepare this for you if the
proposal is small in scale you may wish
to prepare this yourself council
planners can give you guidance on this
an AE e describes the effects of your
proposed activity on the surrounding
environment and on your neighbors the
complexity of your assessment will
depend on the scale of your proposal
let's look at some things that would
normally trigger a resource consent
Andrea wants to extend her garden area
and needs to do some earthworks at the
back of her property and her assessment
of the environmental effects she details
how they go into landscape and build a
retaining wall to protect the bank from
slips and reduce the visual effects John
wants to construct a second-story on his
house his assessment of effects would
need to consider if the addition will
have an unfair impact on his neighbors
such as shading and loss of privacy
Susie wants to open a childcare center
she will need to identify and assess any
potential effects such as noise in
traffic she may put up acoustic fencing
and provide a traffic management plan to
mitigate adverse effects of noise and
traffic if you think that your activity
may have an effect on your neighbor then
you should seek their approval council
will assist your proposal and then visit
your property they will assess the
effects on your neighbors and the
surrounding area if you have provided
your neighbors written approval with
your application then the planner will
not need to consider if they are
affected as long as all the relevant
information is supplied council will
provide you with a decision after 20
working days if your resource consent is
granted make sure you read and
understand your conditions the
posle must be undertaken as shown on
your plans so make sure you get it right
first time as it may be difficult to
change later
[Music]